Speaker 1: Let's go to Stoney from Indiana. Stoney
from Indiana, welcome to the program. What's on
your mind today?
Speaker 3:
Yeah. Yeah. Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can. Stony, welcome.
Speaker 3: Awesome. Thank you. Yeah.
So I had a question, obviously,
either whether you Republican or Democrat,
everyone knows funding is how our system runs.
I find it interesting in a state like Indiana,
for example, with you overturning Roe v Wade,
there's no real way to support that other than
donating to. Certain nonprofit organizations.
But for example, there's fundraising through
like license plates. So there's, you know,
Reilly's Children's Hospitals even have one for
Tony Stewart, who is a murderer, as we all know.
But there's nothing for abortion. So do you
know why that is or how you can change that?
Speaker 1: I don't. So just so I understand,
Tony, you're talking about how in some states
there's these, like pro-life license plates
where when you choose it, it's like I remember
up in Massachusetts, you could get one
that was like Cape Cod and the islands,
and a little money went to conservation. Or you
could get one. That was whatever. You're saying
that there are states where you're basically
a portion of your vanity plate goes to an
anti-abortion charity, but you've never seen
one that goes to a pro-choice organization.
Speaker 2: Exactly.
Speaker 1: I haven't either.
And I don't know the answer to I don't
know why. I genuinely have no idea why.
Speaker 3: I've seen I've done a bit of research
on it, but it's a bit convoluted. There's a
round 14 states or so that offer something
around that range that offers some sort of
pro-life sort of plea, I believe. I mean,
I'm not a lawyer, but from what I've read,
if you have like a nonprofit organization, they
can submit and have it approved. And it started,
of course, in Florida with Jeb Bush, sued and got
it overturned. It's got an interesting history.
But from what I've been able to gather, the
only state that you can really find this in
are obviously like California and Oregon and
places like that. But in the Midwest, for example,
you can't you can find religious vanity plates.
You can We have, you know, 60 different available
options to us, even the Boy Scouts, Girl Scouts,
etc.. But there's nothing for us everyday people
to support pro-life and be be able to.
Speaker 1: I think you
need to support pro-choice, Right.
Speaker 2: You are pro-choice? Yes. Yes.
Speaker 1: Correct. Yeah. I mean, listen, if
it's as you describe, then it sounds like it
requires the activism of submitting and then
getting enough votes to make that an option
in states. I don't know enough about it, but
if that's the case, it's a question of getting
an activist campaign going to demand it.
Speaker 3: Yes, I agree. I think it's just
one simple way we can give back. Yeah. For
that. So. Yeah. Thank you very much, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Stoney from Indiana, thank
you very much for the call. I appreciate that.
Why don't we go next? Just I mean, listen, we're
taking calls. We're all here. We're connected.
Let's just talk to a few other people. Let's go to
Ellen from New York. Ellen from New York. Welcome
to the program. What's going on?
Speaker 2: And can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Okay. You recently talked
about about including nuclear energy as a way to
combat climate change. And I was more interested
in nuclear energy starts to grow. Do you think
that maybe we should start considering thorium as
an energy source? Have you heard of thorium?
Speaker 1: I've heard about it. I don't
know enough about it to be able to really
say, you know, we did an interview about,
you know, vision and fusion and the
advancement there. And we've talked about
new nuclear as a bridge to totally renewable
green energy, etc.. I just don't know enough
about thorium to intelligently weigh in on it.
Speaker 2: Oh, can I give you some examples
as to what I've heard to convince you?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, are you
actually knowledgeable enough? You're not just
spitballing here. You actually know about it.
Speaker 2: I did some research on it.
I'm a physics major and I studied.
So there's some random articles on Dorian.
Speaker 1: Okay, well, tell me. Tell me what it
is. Explain to me in the simplest terms, this is
a real test of whether one understands something,
whether you can explain it in really simple terms.
Speaker 2: But thorium is, as far as I understand,
Territorian on the priority table is
no atomic number is number 90. It's
three times more available to the planet than
uranium. It's easier to mine. It has higher
concentrations in his or than uranium. And one
of the things that scientists are saying that.
It's the science, the study says, is
that it does well with plutonium. It
can produce up to 30 times more energy than
uranium, and which is up to two times more,
which is 2.5. Once on earth or
young can produce up to 2.5 million
and one tonne of thorium is equal to a green of
energy, equivalent to 2.5 million tonnes of coal
and is much more cleaner and efficient than I ran
on a coal mine. I'm sorry, I'm spitballing, but
that's what I'm pulling for from my brain.
Speaker 1: Okay. Well, listen, I mean,
it sounds interesting. I don't know that
right now I'm going to learn enough about
it to be able to weigh in, but let me research it.
Speaker 2: Okay. It's just an interesting topic,
and I feel that with nuclear energy being
more acceptable, particularly I'm not sure
how much to let accept it. I think we should
consider all our options instead of just I
know we're finding renewable energy, but I think
we should consider all our options in regarding
a serious issue like climate change.
Speaker 1: We should always consider
all of our options that I'm with you.
Speaker 2: Okay. And also a quick question
on now that. Now that we're heading into
the 224 election season, do you think
what other message mean matters? Do you think the
levees are improving in terms of marketing their.
Ensure that whatever candidates
are. Whatever the agenda is for
the upcoming elections day. So before we get.
Speaker 1: To tactics, before we even get to
tactics, the left has to dramatically improve
its messaging and decide on exactly what the
platform and and the sales pitch essentially
is going to be. The left is a little bit all
over the place on that. Before we even talk
about marketing tactics. They got they got
to figure that out. All right, my friend,
I appreciate the call. Thank you so much.
Speaker 2: I think you, Howard.
Speaker 1: All right. A lot of
things on people's minds today. Very, very much
things on people's minds, which is important.